foreign
[Music]
what's up y'all Sean here and this is
going to be a different type of episode
this is a I'm calling a master class so
uh Master Class didn't invite me to do a
master class because I'm not famous
um but F them I'm gonna do it myself I
know how to do some things really really
well one of which is pitching and so if
you're listening to this on the podcast
feed uh it's gonna be slightly not ideal
because I'm gonna share my screen I'm
going to show I'm going to give away one
of my little assets which is my dummy
pitch deck so this is
literally a template for how I do my
pitch Decks that is uh for any business
that's trying to raise money uh you want
to send a deck to an investor and you
want to have them understand what you're
doing be excited about what you're doing
and cut you the check this is a deck
that I have used to raise money I have
sent to other Founders or help them
raise money I also in my power writing
course this is one of the modules uh
this is one of the examples one of the
templates I give away so normally people
pay a thousand dollars to take that
course this is one of the little things
in there I'm giving this away for free
right now so if you're on the podcast
feed you're not going to be able to see
my screen so what I recommend you do hit
pause open YouTube type in my first
million
that's find our Channel subscribe to it
and uh and now you um you will be able
to see the screen here because it's
gonna be a lot better with the visuals
but if you're on YouTube already all
right you're here so here's um let's let
me pull this up so this is my dummy
pitch deck and uh by the way I'm doing
this kind of live and improvise I
haven't looked at this in a little while
so there might be some uh some funky
stuff going on but that's okay we'll
we'll improvise as we go so the first
thing is uh your title and a small
subtitle explaining what you do and as
we go through this pitch deck I'm going
to
um write in an example from that that I
had done with a Founder uh in our power
riding course okay so for example uh
here with this is your title so they go
we are shuni and I was like okay what
the heck is that and they go um you know
first they said we are an app for people
with insomnia and I said okay that's
kind of
you know that's that's okay well it's a
subtitle that says the outcome
um and maybe your special sauce and so
this is where we landed on so we go they
said we are helping Millions
millions of people fix their insomnia
with skills parentheses not pills
so that took a little bit of
workshopping to get that one liner but
when you have that one liner
feels so good uh when you get that one
liner so I think this is great what are
we doing we are out here trying to help
millions of people fix their insomnia
with skills not pills all right so
that's your first line first slide now
let's get to the good stuff so this is
where you want to you if you have
credibility you want to lead with it
which is basically in the beginning of
any pitch an investor is trying to
figure out should I even care should I
listen and should I listen it's going to
come down to one of two things number
one
um do you have something that I want so
that's kind of what the title slide sort
of hints at what do you what do you
actually do and the second is
um or are you somebody that uh is legit
are you worth listening to do you have
credibility or some some gravity to you
about what you've done so if you have
accomplishments I like putting that as
slide two so a bit of credibility uh if
you have some accomplishments set the
stage this is your quick intro which
sounds polite but it's actually a place
to Humble brag and um if you or a
company doesn't have accomplishments
then skip this slide don't put this here
you don't want to lead with I'm not that
interesting so uh in suny's case I go
why you know do you have any credibility
and they go well our co-founder or our
partner is this guy Matthew Walker who
wrote This Book why we sleep it's a and
I was like oh I've heard of that book
it's like a bestseller they go yeah
exactly so I go perfect so our title
became we literally wrote the book on
sleep
um and then basically I explain
um our co-founders or you know our
Founders book
why we sleep is a New York Time Best
Seller with over x million copies
sold or whatever the thing is
um
so that's like one of them and then you
know the other person
and I'm uh AI research scientist who has
who was responsible for a 500 million
dollar Plus
is you know business
unit at Accenture
uh we built this app in five weeks and
have
uh over you know whatever XXX
downloads with zero paid
expect right so something like this
you're trying to show that you're highly
highly credible and then you know I
would put the you know the the
um like the title of the book you know
the the recognizable image or some image
here
um in in big words and again forget the
formatting right like I'm not working on
slide design right now that's why I just
took the times do Roman black font white
slide because I'm not worried about
design that will come at the end we'll
do that later for now it's what is the
story what is the storyline that's going
to get somebody hooked so here we're
saying uh we have a compelling initial
thing we're helping millions of people
fix insomnia with skills not pills
secondly we're legit you should listen
to us we literally wrote the book on
sleep one of the best sellers we wrote
that I'm a good business person an
engineer that's the dynamic duo that's
going to build this thing okay great so
now you're going to say most customers
have this problem
and it's going to be backed by either
really compelling data or a personal
story
um and so you know I'm gonna just copy
paste kind of what I did for them here
so most customers have this problem for
that we did 25 of Americans have have
insomnia that's 75 million people right
and then we added to that
the personal story so that became
including me I had insomnia for years I
tried pills but felt yucky I tried to
send some oils that did nothing finally
I found something that worked okay so
this is your problem slide your problem
slide with a big headline number that
punches you in the face shows how big of
a problem it is and ideally maybe a
personal connection to it I had this
problem I knew this problem I either I
had this problem or I was a doctor and I
saw thousands of patients who had this
problem I've helped treat thousands of
patients to have this problem right so
something like that that connects you to
the problem is ideal
and then you want to do the current
solution so before what what people are
tempted to do is say here's my solution
here's why we're so great
um instead you want to say here's how
they try to fix it today so what we did
for this was we said
so how we solve it today we did
Americans spend 75 billion dollars per
year on sleep aids to try to fix their
sleep problems they barely work they
have side effects and they're mostly
using fake science right so that's what
we put as the uh the secondary thing
here
um and then here I would maybe put some
images of the categories right so I
would put like uh you know whatever some
shape here so let me get a little shape
I'd be like uh you know pills or you
know sleeping sleeping pills is x
billion dollars
um whatever you know nasal strips is
this you know what whatever the whatever
the other sleep aids you know essential
oils or
whatever people use to solve this
problem so I would kind of show they try
a b and c none of that works
and this is where you now come in with
the Steve Jobs moment you get your
turtleneck on and you say but what if
instead there was a simpler solution a
beautiful solution a solution that
totally fixed this problem with no
downsides whatsoever all right this is
essentially what you're gonna say and so
um
you know this is where for them
we basically came in and we said
um you know
instead here's our solution
you know
instead we built an app
that will uh teach you how to sleep
without having to take medicine
so that's the headline that would come
here and then
beautiful picture of your product
um and then you kind of reinforce it
right like that's us we do that thing
um you know so if you if you gave a
hypothetical here like what if there was
an app that did Blakely blank then you
say that's us we do that thing or in
this case just put it all on one side
that's fine
now here's the key thing that most
people miss so what they do typically is
they go solution and then they just go
solution solution solution they start
talking about how the solution Works
under the hood everything about the
solution as an investor you don't need
to know how the whole product works yet
you instead need to know is this big am
I going to make money right that's what
the receiver of this presentation really
wants to know
am I betting on credible people are they
solving a big problem does their
solution make sense and how big can this
get so now we go here we State the dream
so we explain the big plan the big
vision for how big this company could
become
you know this is where you might say
we're we're building Uber for Freight
Trucking right that's like we're
building this big thing in this big
industry
um that's 100 billion dollar industry
that's totally broken
um you know so I so as an investor I'm
thinking wow if they actually fix this
problem that would be a big deal
um so you know for these guys what they
did was we said
this
our Dream what calm and headspace you
know two billion dollar company one
billion company did for meditation we
are going to do for insomnia depression
and anxiety and then
you know we then added the sort of
subtext these are 200 billion dollar
annual markets it's 50 times bigger than
meditation
um and then we we follow on again we
make this even more persuasive so you
want to Anchor it to something that they
already know
and then you want to
um
so why did we use headspace and calm or
why do we use it's Uber for x uh because
it anchors into something they
understand something that they know
right we're building yeah I built an
Esports app and I said we're building
Little League baseball for Fortnight or
for Esports okay Little League Baseball
produces x hundred million dollars a
year
um we're going to be but but more people
play fortnite than play baseball this is
going to be a bigger business than even
the little league is and so we were able
to take something that sounded very
Niche right like youth Esports but make
it sound a lot bigger by pitching it
connecting it to something that's
already big and then saying we're doing
that but in this big space so
um
so you know here's here's where this
slide landed people with these illnesses
are sick of taking pills for every
problem we can get clinically verified
results with habit-based app therapy
um and I think the key here is
what this thing you recognize did for
the X we're doing for y y is much bigger
than x 50 times bigger than x
and people really have this problem all
right so now you're going to get to your
attraction slide again as an investor
I'm trying to figure out is this
actually going to work the easiest way
to answer that question is to say it's
already working look at this so so
far so good and this is where you put an
impressive chart
um so your what is your hero chart how
can you show that this thing is working
so what is your what is your most hero
metric and this is where pitching can't
save you if your chart sucks your pitch
is going to kind of suck
um you know no pitch can fix a terrible
business you shouldn't be pitching a
terrible business you should be pitching
a business that's working or going to
work and so you want to if it's already
working you wanna show that if it's
going to work you want to say why you
believe it's going to work maybe you
have a wait list that's really big maybe
um
you have a track record of doing this
with other products
um you know what can you show that would
give me faith that this isn't all just
talk there's some evidence so this is
where you put your hero chart
now you go back to under the hood so now
you're gonna say all right now you're
interested correct I told you the
problem the solution the big vision of
how big this can be and the evidence
that we're on our way
so now what you're going to do is you're
going to say
let me tell you how we're different
right uh does this already exist is this
really that different than anything else
and this is where you're going to
highlight your differentiator what most
people do is they just explain their
features that's not what you want to do
you want to say everybody does X and we
do y right that's the core
differentiator so
let me tell you how our approach is
different yet sensible others do X we do
y and this is where you're talking about
either your product strategy your
business model your growth strategy Etc
right everybody else charges for this
stuff we give it to them at cost but we
have a annual subscription
that's Costco
um it might be product you know
everybody else tries to solve this
problem with pills we do it with skills
through this app that teaches you daily
habits right
um everybody else tries to grow through
paid marketing but we do YouTube content
that gets millions of views and
therefore we're able to you know acquire
customers for pennies where everybody
else is paying ten dollars right this is
the the type of thing that you're gonna
do product business model or growth
strategy how are you different than
everybody else
[Music]
worst have you heard of HubSpot see most
crms are a cobble together mess but
HubSpot is easy to adopt and actually
looks gorgeous I think I love our new
CRM our software is the best HubSpot
grow better
[Music]
now we zoom out is there a bigger Trend
that you're a part of again this is all
about instilling confidence confidence
confidence confidence
um
are you know one way to instill
confidence is we're not alone doing this
this is something that you're seeing the
whole world is moving remote
um you know the you know the way that
Peloton did this for Fitness we're doing
this over here in this other space so
you want to be able to zoom out and show
that you're part of a bigger Trend so in
their case I asked them this question I
said what bigger Trends are you you guys
a part of
and they ended up telling me we didn't
we didn't design the slide but there's
three big trends one is app-based
coaching calm headspace they've proven
that people will do application the next
one is telemedicine they're a billion
dollar companies now that people are
comfortable getting doctors and a
doctor's advice over the phone and
lastly is that insomnia depression
anxiety are rising due to
technology overload the pandemic the
recession the whatever else and so we
are we are surfing these big waves we're
not the big wave ourself we are surfing
the big waves
now you want to answer the why now
question so can you explain why this
idea would work today but it wouldn't
work three years ago or five years ago
or ten years ago what has changed did a
rule change did uh technology change did
social behaviors change and so um you
know for example in their case when we
brainstormed and again it's not about
slide design it's about being able to
make a persuasive case and so each of
these slides is part of your persuasive
case this is your why now
so why now well this wouldn't have
worked five years ago regulation did not
allow for digital therapy with licensed
doctors so there's regulatory inflection
point also in the last two years due to
covet everybody had to have a telemed
medicine experience we went from 10 of
people having tried telemedicine to 80
in two years so the whole world got to
sample this and now has an experience
doing this there are to be more
comfortable today than they would have
been you know X years ago
okay why are you the one to do it what's
your track record your credibility your
expertise you want to reinforce what we
did up top or if you didn't write that
up top you want to write it here so this
is your why you
um okay now
the business part how do you make money
doing this if I give you some money you
know uh what will happen and so this is
where
um
usually I actually kind of left one out
here so what I would do here is I would
separate these I would do
how the money gets made this is where
you do your unit economics so you show
that you've actually thought this
through that the business is sensible uh
you know we put in X dollars it costs us
why to produce the product or service
and Z is the the net profit at the end
at the end of it and so you know for
these guys they were able to say
we make a hundred dollars per session at
25 net margin here's our and then they
had a graph of their unit economics and
their payback period so they their
payback period was
um they acquired users for X dollars and
that means they break even in three
months on that user so so three books is
a good good payback period so that's the
unit economic side now you're gonna do
the uh
what Milestones will you hit so if I
give you this money how will you make
this the
um
uh how will you make this the the big um
you know the big big results so you know
here's yeah you know how will you make
progress of that the valuation goes up
and my shares become worth more
uh so you know this is what we came up
with for them
which was the raisy 2 million to do
their pilot to get our first 5 000
paying customers
key drivers uh allow people uh in from
the you know what are we gonna do to get
there we're going to allow people in
from the wait list we're gonna hire
three more coaches and we're gonna roll
out our company plan that lets
corporations buy this for their
employees so those are the key things
we're going to do to get to 1 million
ARR and now I'm telling you if you give
me two million dollars I'll turn that
into one million out of annual recurring
Revenue
um also on the uh Yu we had a good
version of it for them uh so you know
I'm a fan of being bold with the stuff
so we're the team for this we're world
renowned Sleep Experts and AI Engineers
instead and then we wrote this instead
of trying to get people to play eight
hours of Candy Crush uh per day we've
decided to help people help everyone get
gets better sleep at night right so I
kind of like this this vocal style of
being a little bit ballsy not everybody
loves that
um and sure it could turn some people
off but you want to attract the type of
investor that uh likes you and so you
know as long as you attract as long as
some people love it it's okay that some
people hate it you you know as long as
it's just not everybody hates it
um all right now this is one thing I see
a lot of people miss out on sweeten the
pot so you want to take some of your
good news and move 15 of it to the end
of the end of the show so what can you
say for the end it's like your little
good news dessert at the end of the at
the end of the thing so
um for them they're
pot sweetener was this
oops
um
they said one last thing we just secured
a partnership with NIH they're going to
be giving us 500 000 in this round no
dilution there's over 2 billion in sleep
funding grants available and we will tap
into this as we grow
nice uh just a little bit of good news
at the end that shows more momentum more
progress a key partnership you just had
uh maybe it's a revenue Milestone or
it's um you know some some key thing
that's that you didn't put in your main
traction you just took a little bit of
good news out saved it for the end to
leave them on a high note and this is at
the end call to action so get in touch
um you know well we're closing out this
round if you're interested email me here
uh here's my email address that's
that's my dummy pitch deck uh I kind of
messed up my template here I can uh I
can make this available so if you just
go to
um
I'll make a a link for this so just go
to seanpuri.com slash uh deck d-e-c-k
I'll put a link to this here so you can
go and download this and have a copy of
this for yourself and you can edit it
with your stuff so I'll clean this up
I'll revert all these so it goes back to
the template and then um you can use
this for your stuff so
try this out let me know what you think
um it's pretty battle tested so you know
I've definitely been there the hard part
for most of you is going to be you don't
have good stuff to put on some of the
slides you don't have a different chair
or you don't have traction or you don't
have a pot sweetener or you don't have a
great track record and that's where you
you're you will learn what part of your
business is weak why would a smart
investor not invest in this and you need
to go fix those problems because it's if
you do use this deck you will be able to
raise money as long as you actually have
good content to put inside if your
business is not very good then don't
worry about the deck make your business
better first then go raise the money so
anyways that's it that's my master class
uh if you liked it let me know if you
want me to do more of these I got I got
tons of these things so uh go get this
deck seanpuri.com deck and uh and try it
out let me know let me know how it goes
for you all right that's all
[Music]
thank you